muy bien ahora tenemos todos nuestros
monómeros listos para ser absorbidos
cómo funciona el proceso de absorción
vamos a ver
estamos muy cerca tenemos todos nuestros
monómeros pero tenemos que descubrir
cómo los vamos a meter en nuestro
torrente sanguíneo bueno comencemos con
nuestros aminoácidos estos van a ser
transportados en las células usando lo
que se llama transporte activo primario
transporte activo primario ahora si digo
primario específicamente que indica eso
puedes recordar que cuando usamos
transporte activo significa que
necesitamos un poco de energía para
hacer que algo suceda y la forma de
energía que usamos en el transporte
activo primario proviene del atp la
energía la unidad de la vida adenosina
tri como un 3 fosfato trifosfato de
adenosina si miramos un entero cito a
una célula intestinal habrá una proteína
aquí en la membrana celular esta
proteína romper a nuestro atp dividiendo
uno de los grupos
para liberar adenosina de fosfato así
que esto es 2 y fosfato al hacerlo
permitirá que el aminoácido entre en
nuestro entero sito o nuestra célula
intestinal a partir de ahí el aminoácido
puede experimentar un par de pasos
diferentes pero finalmente dejará el
entero sito para ir a un capilar
sanguíneo donde entrará al torrente
sanguíneo y luego podrá transportarse a
cualquier otro lugar del cuerpo para su
uso
los monosacáridos son azúcares y le
sucede algo similar pero en lugar de
transporte activo primario tenemos el
transporte activo secundario de modo que
si usamos el atp para el transporte
activo primario que utilizamos para el
secundario bueno el hecho de que estemos
diciendo transporte activo significa que
hay algo de energía que se usó en algún
momento y la energía en realidad se
invirtió en enviar un gradiente de iones
entonces el gradiente de iones podría
usarse permitiendo que algo como el
sodio fluya por su gradiente para ir
desde el lugar de alta concentración
la concentración donde puede relajarse y
al permitir que eso ocurra la energía se
aprovecha permitiendo que un
monosacárido o un azúcar entre nuestro
entero sito para asegurarnos que
entendemos voy a dibujar aquí el
transportador de proteínas que tenemos
también en el otro lado y mostraré que
hay unión de sodio que fluye hacia
nuestro entero sito bajando su gradiente
de concentración para terminar en el
entero cito con el azúcar y pasa lo
mismo del otro lado excepto que mientras
el azúcar se va el sodio entra en este
lado así que en sodio baja su gradiente
de concentración pero termina dentro del
entero cito mientras que el azúcar se va
al capilar sanguíneo también termina en
nuestro torrente sanguíneo y puede ir a
cualquier parte del cuerpo para ser
utilizado el núcleo ha sido en la base
usa el mismo mecanismo que los
aminoácidos solo voy a escribir
transporte activo primario por aquí
puedes echar un vistazo arriba para ver
cómo sucede y al hacerlo puedes imaginar
dónde van a terminar así es en el
capital sanguíneo
y eso nos lleva a nuestra última
macromolécula los lípidos ahora lo que
pasa con los lípidos es ridículo porque
en realidad tienen esta cola no polar si
alguna vez aparece junto a un entero
citó como este lo único que tiene que
hacer es pasar a través de la membrana y
así terminar en el interior en el entero
citó todos nuestros ácidos grasos se
reorganizan en lo que se llaman kilo
micrones y al igual que su nombre los
kilómetro ones son demasiado grandes
para entrar directamente en un capilar
sanguíneo ni siquiera cabe en este
entero citó así que en realidad no van
directamente al capilar sanguíneo son
demasiado grandes para hacerlo demasiado
grandes para ir al capilar sanguíneo en
cambio los kilómetro ones serán
absorbidos en lo que llamamos capilar
linfático también conocido como lácteo
un capilar linfático estos son lo
suficientemente grandes como para
acomodar a los kilo micrones aquí van a
ser digeridos aún más y se descompondrán
en pedazos más pequeños para terminar en
las venas
enviaran los lípidos digeridos a través
del corazón y finalmente a las arterias
que podrán distribuirlos por el cuerpo
donde sea que se necesiten puedes ver
que aquí suceden muchas cosas hemos
hablado sobre cómo nuestras cuatro
principales macromoléculas se digieren
en el duodeno el lugar donde se produce
la mayor digestión en el tracto
gastrointestinal ahora acabamos de
hablar sobre cómo se absorben muy
probablemente en el yeyuno porque en el
yeyuno es donde ocurre la mayor
absorción del tracto gastrointestinal y
así es como funciona nuestro intestino
delgado